IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC OUR LEGISLATORS ARE
EMPLOYEES WE LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO THE
PROPER SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES SOME
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ALLOWED THE PUBLIC TO BE HERE
INTO HEARING ROOMS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. AND WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. SO FOR THE
WORD INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT BY
TELEPHONE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT'LL ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I'LL READ IT TO YOU
NOW. IT IS. 1-844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN TWO ZERO
SIX SIX SEVEN NINE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THE
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
YOU WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN A
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU'LL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. AND PLEASE NOTE THAT
WHEN YOU ARE ABOUT TO ADDRESS
S. MUTE THE DEVICE YOU MAY BE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR YOU AND WE DON'T
GET FEEDBACK. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARING SINCE CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE. OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES. WILL BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS ARE ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. WE'RE HEARING ONE BILL
TODAY. IT IS A B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO- LET'S SEE I DON'T
THINK I CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM
NOW I COULD HAVE A SECOND AGO
BUT- WHATEVER WE BE AND-
IMMEDIATE. I GET A QUORUM. BUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIRMAN
CHAIRWOMAN AND SENATORS I AM RE
PRESENTING- A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO WANT TO START OFF BY
THANKING CENTER INNER FOR
PRESENTING THIS BILL LAST WEEK
A BILL THAT WILL GIVE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
CIVIL FINES ON GUN DEALERS WHO
DO NOT COMPLY WITH OUR CAN
SAFETY LAWS I STAND THAT I
BELIEVE OF CENTER JACKSON THAT
RAISED THE QUESTION LAST WEEK
OR THE BE- COMMENT. THAT
COVERED CIVIL FIND A DOLLARS
SHOULD GO TO A SPECIAL K.
ACCOUNT BUT WE HAVE ATTEMPTED
TO ADDRESS THAT CONCERN BY
SUBMITTING- AN AMENDMENT TO
THIS COMMITTEE A LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD DIRECT THE OFF LINE
DOLLARS TO THE DROSE ACCOUNT-
IN FRTHERANCE OF THE OBJECTIVE
OF THIS BILL. TO STEP UP OUR-
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ENFORCEMENT OF FIREARMS
RELATED- REGULATORY ACTIVITIES.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
OVER TO- THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL- REBEKAH MARCUS OF WITH
THE BRADY UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE. BEIN FOLLOWING- MISS
MARCUS WE HAVE ASHLEY ERRORS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. WHO IS- THERE
DUBBED DEPARTMENT OF WHICH IS
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
BEFORE OUR LEAD- WITNESSES
BEGAN LET ME JUST STATE THAT.
THE YOU'RE THE LEAD WITNESSES
YOUR TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES NOT
THREE MINUTES EACH AND THEN-
WINTER CONCLUDED WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY ONE ON THE PHONE
ANYONE HERE FRED PHYSICALLY
PRESENT OR ON THE PHONE LINES
TO TESTIFY. AND THEN WILL
SWITCH OVER TO OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT SO A REBEKAH MARKETS
FINANCIALLY OURS MODERATOR EVAN
BEGIN IF THEY'RE ON THE LINE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO. LET ME STEP.
THE CAN WE ESTABLISH QUORUM
SORRY A ROLL CALL. SENATOR
SKINNER I'M PRESENT IN OUR
PRESENT MORE A LOT MORE LIKE
PRESENT BRADFORD BRADFORD
PRESENT JACKSON JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL. MITCHELL HERE MARA.
WIENER. WIENER HERE ALL RIGHT
PAUL JEEZ WE CAN GO BACK TO
LET'S SEE IF ASHLEY OURS
REBEKAH MARCUS ARE. WHICHEVER
ONES ON THE LINE CAN BEGIN. HEY
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKETS
ON BEHALF OF BRADY BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION THERE MUST
BE A FOCUS ON THE UPSTREAM
SOURCE OF CRIME GUNS
INFILTRATING COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE AND A PARTICULAR
IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO WOULD
BRING ABOUT REASONABLE
PENALTIES AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND DEALERS HIGHLY A LOT WE ASK
ABOUT. READ THE NUMBER BACK-
THAT WAS REBEKAH SORRY. RESET
ASHLEY I'M SORRY I DID NOT THE
NEXT LEAD WITNESS PLEASE. THREE
OF THE OTHER MANAGER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. GO AHEAD GO
AHEAD THE BEST PLAYERS COULD
NOT BEAR TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JSTICE. ON
BEHALF OF THE TENTH OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOW THE
ADDRESS I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
IT'S ONLY NUMBER MIGHT BE
CHEAPER RE PRESENTING ITSELF
TODAY. I CAN MAKE ONE POINT
THAT I MADE LAST WEEK THAT THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST BILL OF ITS
KIND TO CONTEMPLATE FINDING
THINGS OF THIS NATURE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE NOT THE DEPARTMENT IS
EVALUATING THE UP BACK AT. THE
FOURTEENTH DECEMBER WITH
CURRENTLY ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS AND THE IMPACT
THAT BILL WOULD HAVE ON THE
WILL FIND AN EVEN THAT YOUR
COMMENTS AND BY TWENTY THREE
YOU. HAVE FOR IT. HAVE A LOOK.
AS FOR REGULATORY NOT AND BY
WILL CRIMINAL NOT QUOTING A
HELP THANK YOUR ENVIRONMENT
THREAT. HER AS A POTENTIAL
WAIVER. FELL ME ABOUT THE WE
WILL HAVE TO. THE BATTLE IN THE
WHEN IMPLEMENTING REGULATORY
POLICY OF CRITICALLY CAN'T AND
RESPECT AND I DON'T THINK IT
THANK YOU. OUR LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER WITNESS AND-
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE OTHER
HEARING ROOM NOT. SO MODERATOR
YOU CAN QUEUE UP ANY WITNESSES
WHO ARE CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME
ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST.
COMMON THANK. IN OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
FROM LINE TWENTY SIX POINT
TWENTY SIX PLEASE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS STEVE GOMEZ AND I'M
AFFILIATED WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
RIFLE PISTOL ASSOCIATION I'M A
MEMBER OF THEM ALONG WITH THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
NATIONAL WILD TURKEY CRANBERRY
SHARING CALIFORNIA BEER AND
MANY OTHER CONSERVATION GROUPS
AND AYE OPPOSED AB. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU
MODERATE LET'S SEE LET'S CALL
FOR SUPPORT JUST MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO'S
CALLED IN AND SUPPORT AND THEN
WILL SWITCH OVER TO OPPOSITION.
ABSOLUTELY AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN GENERAL
AT THIS TIME. AND IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU EXCELLENT. THEN WE HAD
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION I'M
NOT SURE IF THEY'RE ON THE
LINE. MICHAEL FINDLAY FROM THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION AND DAN READ FROM
THE NRA. MODERATOR ARE THEY ON
THE LINE. IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO
HAVE DAN REED ON THE LINE AND
DAN'S MIND IS OPEN AT THIS TIME
GREAT GO AHEAD DAN. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE RECORD AND RE WITH
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALL
OF YOUR OPPOSITION PREVENT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA TODAY.
POLITICAL LOOK AT THE PILOT TO
GOT. A REFERENCE MONEY IN
INCORPORATED RECORD TODAY IN
AUSTIN PRETTY QUESTIONS ANYONE
MAY HELP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT. BYE NOW
MODERATOR YOU CAN CHECK INS-
QUEUE UP ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO
CALL IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IT'LL BE ONE
MOMENT BEFORE OUR FIRST.
CONTACT. IN OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE TEN LINE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS AS A WAY
TO BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION ARE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA YOUR EXPRESS OUR
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY ALIVE THIS
IS NOT THE TIME TO PLACE PLEASE
UNNECESSARY FINES ON THEM AND
CERTAINLY NOT IN THE INTEREST
IN RECOVERING OUR STAGE
INCREDIBLE ECONOMY. THE JUNE
DOJ'S OWN RECORD IS ESTIMATED
OVER TEN THOUSAND ARBOR HERE TO
CHALLENGE STILL FREELY ROAM OUR
STREETS. LET'S NOT HAVE DOJ
DOGS PAPERWORK VIOLATIONS AT
BIG LAW ABIDING BUSINESSESAND
LAW ABIDING CALIFORNIANS BUT
INSTEAD OF HIM GETTING
DANGEROUS KAMEL. OUR STREETS
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW FROM THIS POINT ON ANYONE
ELSE WHO'S CALLING IN OFFICE
JUST YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
MODERATOR GO AHEAD ANYBODY.
ELSE CUED UP. YES ONE OF LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO MADAM CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS RYAN ONE THAT
WHEN WE FIREARMS CALLING WITH-
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION TO WERE EXPRESSED
BY OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. SIX
ONE MOTOR NINE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- I'M SURE THIS IS
CARLENE ELLIS I AM A
RECREATIONAL AND COMPETITIVE
PISTOL SHOOTER NUMBER OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO- CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION.
THE INTERNATIONAL DEFENSIVE
PISTOL SHOOTERS AND PROCREATION
THE SACRAMENTO DEFENSIVE PISTOL
SHOOTERS AND THE FOLSOM
SHOOTING CLUB AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. GREAT MOTOR.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOSHUA ELLIS AND I AM A MEMBER
OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION AND A FIREFIGHTER'S
BALL AND I AM CALLING TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG OPPOSITION.
TO AB TWO THREE SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DARREN BUT
WHILE I AM A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION THAT ASSISTED WITH
THE TALK ABOUT THE CRIMINAL
CHAPTER CALLING IN A STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE- MEASURE
THANK YOU. AND LINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME MY NAME IS JACK BRAND
ARE FROM CALLING FROM RED
RIFLED ONE IN CARSON CALIFORNIA
BOMBS RECALLING THE STRONGLY
OPPOSED AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
TWO WE ARE IN A MINORITY
COMMUNITY DOWN HERE. OUR GUN
STORE HAD THANK YOU. I JUST
NAME AN AFFILIATION THANK YOU
MODERATOR. LINE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY IS BEING LISTED AS
KING PRESIDENT AND OWNER OF A
MOTOR SHOULD ASSUME QUORUM AND
PRESIDENT OF RAMONA SPORTSMAN'S
CLUB- I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I AM HERE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BILL GAINS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FOR CONSERVATION THE
BLACK BRAND GROUP AND THE CAL
OR WETLANDS. BALCATTA
PROPOSITION BABY TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. AND ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS
JOHN MCKENNA CHAIR THE KERN
COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHAT'S ON
DISASSOCIATION AS WELL AS YOUR
P. BOARD MEMBER INTERRELATION
EMBER MEMBER OF CURRENT
SHOOTING SPORTS I WANT TO
SUPPORT A STRONG OPPOSITION TO.
THE TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO. TEN
NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEREMY
COMMITTEE MICHAEL GARNER
RETIRED SERGEANT LONG BEACH
POLICE DEPARTMENT CHAIRMAN OF
THE C. RPA COASTAL COMMISSION
WHITE CRIME IN OUR A MEMBER AN
OLDER REAL WORLD SHOOTING LIKE
TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. AND NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FINDINGS KEEP COOL RUNNING
OPERATIONS MANAGER SACRAMENTO.
THE VALLEY SHOOTING CENTER- WE
ARE THE MOST OF DOZENS OF LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AS- TO
STRENGTHENING. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE MY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. AT
NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE. ON A TWO OUTOF
CALIFORNIA RIFLE DISASSOCIATION
AND ENTER A MEMBER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
TEN NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MICHAEL CAN MEET
WITH THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR AMERICA'S
FIREARM AMMUNITION HUNTING AND
RECREATIONAL SPORTS INDUSTRY.
WOULD LIKE TO AT THIS TIME
OPPOSEAB. TWO THREE SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
TEN NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CANDY
LIEBERMAN AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER- AND FFL IN LAKE FOR
CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF THE
EUROPEAN DAY AND THE NRA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. TEN NINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE THIS
DEMOCRAT ON THE TRIGGER OF THE
SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. NUMBER AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I'M
TWENTY- INTERNET LINE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHARE NUMBER OF
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAID HE
DID ON THE MEMBERS FROM THE
LIFETIME MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
THAT. THE LIST OF CHF AND YEN
ALREADY AND I'M CALLING ON THE
PHONE AB THROUGH CHRISTIAN
PEOPLE THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. VENTURE MONEY IS TAKEN
PLATE TRADER AND MEMBER OF THE
KERN COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND THEN I
REMEMBER- CALLING IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO.
THANK. AT NINE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING OPPOSITION MY NAME IS
ROBERT MONEY MAKER I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
AT THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION. LIFETIME
MEMBER OF THE NRA AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF PHEASANTS FOREVER AND
I VOICE MY STRONG OPPOSITION TO
BILL TWO THREE SIX TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AT NINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN IS POLL LANG I'M A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND I OPPOSE AB
TWO THREE SIX TWO. IN LINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAN TOWARD
AUSTIN I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
KERN COUNTY CHAPTER SECRETARY
I'M ALSO A NRA LIFE MEMBER AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE NOT YET COMMENTED IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR LAST COMMENT IN
Q.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS RICHARD MCCAMISH SUMMERS IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND- AND
CALLING TO OPPOSE H. B. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AM WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
ONE HERE PRESENT IN THE IN OUR
MAIN HEARING ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE I'LL ALSO CHECK THE
SECONDARY ROOM SEEING NOAH AND-
THEN I THINK WE HAVE NOW.
OPTION WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT ON THE PHONE OKAY GO
AHEAD MODERATOR. NINE FORTY.
NINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MA'AM MY
NAME IS ROBERT LEE AND I'M THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE FALL FROM
NORTH SACRAMENTO C. R. HE A
CHAPTER I'M A LIFE MEMBER OF C.
R. G. H. IT HAS ALSO A LIFE
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL WORLD
RIFLE ASSOCIATION AND I'D LIKE
TO OPPOSE AB. TWO SIX THREE SIX
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT ON
THE PHONE. OKAY SO NOW I WILL
TURN MY COLLEAGUES IS ARE ANY-
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ABOUT.
RIGHT WE HAVE A- OCEAN SEEING
NO OTHER COMMENTS HEARD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. RIVAL THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE WILL CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YES AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER AYE MORLOCK OKAY MORE
LIKE NO BRADFORD ALL RIGHT
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE
MORALE AROUND THE WORLD WINNER.
WE ARRIVE. FIVE TO PROVIDE THE
BILL'S OUT FIVE TWO THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER AND TO WITH THAT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. I
THINK THAT MEANS WERE CHURNED
FOR THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
WE MAY- YOU'RE RIGHT YOU'RE
RIGHT WE NEVER NEVER SAY NEVER
AS THEY SAY THERE COULD BE SOME
BILLS THAT COME BACK OVER RIGHT
WELL THANK YOU STAFF- HOPEFULLY
WE'RE DONE BUT WE MAY NOT BE WE
MAY HAVE ANOTHER WORD BUT
ANYWAY FOR THIS SESSION FOR
THIS PARTICULAR COMMITTEE
MEETING WE ARE A JERK.